Many of 3JSs geometry object come along with their own UVs built-in. Some of
these are displayed here. For planar objects, the texture's put flat against
the face. For round objects, the general idea is that the u-value goes from
zero to one, around the equator. And V goes from zero to one, around the axis.
To be honest, the mapping on the bottom of the cone shown here is pretty. But
doesn't make a lot of sense to me. Maybe you'll be the one to fix it. Note that
3JS truly is a work in progress and anyone can submit bug fixes and
improvement. I should also point out the tetrahedron. It's mapping is a bit
distorted. In fact, if you look at the code, no UV mapping is given at all and
3JS creates one using some rules. Sometimes there simply is no natural UV
mapping for the object being made. It's then pretty much up to the programmer
to decide how to proceed. What is happening with each of these objects is that
UVs are generated by the geometry class used to create the triangles. The form
for making a triangle with UVs code. Here, three vertices are defined and put
inside the geometry object. Three UVs are created. I put them in an array so I
can reuse any that I want. A face is defined as usual. The three numbers given
are indices to the three vertex locations in the vertices array. The way the
three UVs are attached to this face is a little non-standard. The first element
of the face vertex UVs is accessed. And the three uv's we want to use for this
face are directly placed there. If you want to add more faces with UVs Note
that you'll access the face vertex UV's class the same way each time. You'll
access a ray element zero and pass in the three UVs desired.